[Musique]
ce soir je souhaite l'interroger avec
vous sur ce que signifie être inclus
être hinault et être exclue out
qu'est ce qui fait que l'on est out ou
in si je vous posais la question
certains me dirais je suis in parce que
je suis la fille d'un tel l'ami de
machin ou lancer une étudiante de
l'école truc mais cela fait-il vraiment
de vous quelqu'un de in un ami en galère
me confiait l'autre jour que pour lui
être out c'est quand personne ne te voit
on a besoin de toi ou ne compte sur toi
qui sont les outs dans mon parcours j'ai
rencontré des personnes qu'on dit out
comme christine et jean paul christine
c'est une jeune mère célibataire
arrivé à paris il ya deux ans elle est
hébergée à l'hôtel social avec sa petite
fille elle ne connaît encore personnes
dans le quartier
christine et cuisinière il vient de
s'inscrire au pôle emploi proches de
chez elle avec l'espoir de retrouver
bientôt du travail christine est
considéré comme out
jean-paul avec une dizaine d'années à la
rue avant l'été jour la liste et il
était marié
lorsque nous sommes rencontré jean-paul
faisait la manche à la sortie du métro
une personne sur dix lui disait bonjour
jean paul aussi est out
sont ils vraiment out et s'il est out
était en réalité une pure invention d in
faisons un pas de côté ayant un regard
différent sur ces personnes
christine est prête à surmonter tous les
obstacles pour offrir un avenir digne à
sa fille elle n'a pas grand chose mais
se réjouit peu et répand de la chaleur
partout où elle passe un cassoulet chez
christine vaut mille fois un resto
étoilé
christine et débrouillarde elle est
responsable elle est battante elle
n'hésite pas à aller de l'avant pour
réaliser ses rêves
jean-paul lui a lu tous les victor hugo
des poètes du 17e au 19e siècle
jean paul est généreux et incroyablement
serviable le jour où tu as besoin d'un
coup de main des la fidèle au poste et
ne ménage pas ses efforts pour le prix
d'un bon moment passé ensemble
bon sang vous ne trouvez pas que les out
sont en fait incroyablement inspirant à
mes yeux ce sont des supers out je veux
les féliciter pour ce qu'ils sont et
pour ce qu'il nous apporte
ils nous interpellent nous déplace nous
empêche de rester dans l'entretoit
ils nous apprennent la gratuité dans la
relation ce que c'est de rencontrer en
profondeur l'autre est d'aller au delà
des apparences vous vous dites peut-être
mais c'est qui celle là pour nous
interpeller sur les personnes exclues
et vous avez raison je ne suis ni
experte ni philosophe une simple fille
de 28 ans habitait d'une conviction ou
plutôt d'une grande motivation que je
souhaite vous partagez en fait je suis
là ce soir car depuis quelques mois je
travaille sur un projet qui s'appelle
linked outs lindhout c'est le réseau
social professionnel de ceux qui n'en
n'ont pas pour faire court c'est un
projet qui permet à des personnes
considérées come out de devenir il
et d'être durablement inclus dans la
société peut-être que comme moi parfois
ça vous arrive d'avoir un regard un peu
facile sur une personne que vous croisez
elle paye pas de mine comme ça à
première vue elles sont même un peu
paumé et en fait ça se trouve cette
personne elle a du génie
par exemple c'est une virtuose du piano
du banjo en fait vous moi nous avons
tous du talent encore faut-il le voir et
s'y intéresser finalement je vous pose
la question
n'y aurait-il pas que des in dont
certains seraient simplement dans
l'ombre
passons à la pratique d'après vous
qu'est ce qui peut mettre en lumière un
talent pour ma part c'est un regard qui
dit je te vois tu veux quelque chose tu
es doué pour ça c'est la rencontre celle
qui permet de dépasser de faire tomber
les murs de la peur et des préjugés car
nous sommes tous ici le out de quelqu'un
qui dans le fond ne nous connaît pas et
que nous ne connaissons pas ce soir je
vais vous proposer une révolution la
révolution du regard je vous lance le
défi à tous deux révélés tous les
talents encore cachés autour de vous
découvrez que la frontière entre les in
et les out en fait n'existe pas et que
la raison d'être des in et peut-être
justement de pouvoir ouvrir leurs
réseaux à ceux qui ont moins de chance
que dans la vie il existe beaucoup de
moyens aujourd'hui pourtant concrètement
la main à des personnes qui ont besoin
d'un coup de pouce pour se relever ou
avancés ligne hta route en est un c'est
un projet où chacun de nous peut agir à
sa mesure à son échelle par exemple en
partageant sur ces réseaux un cv un cv
d'un candidat pour générer des
opportunités d'emploi
en lui donnant sa chanson entreprises en
devenant bénévole coach etc
ce projet ils changent déjà la vie de
personnes il songe la vie de l'être de
manuel d'anaïs de mai l'année et de
beaucoup d'autres pour autant combien
d'entre nous ce soir passerait
concrètement à l'action en partageant un
cv en sortant de cette salle combien en
réalité mon but ce soir c'est de vous
lancer une invitation plus engageante
celle que vous agissiez d'abord sur
vous-même pour mieux agir sur les autres
en effet c'est bien beau de vouloir
révéler les talents des autres mais
comment y arriver véritablement si on ne
s'est pas d'abord révélé soi-même en
êtes-vous les in là tout ce que vous
croyez être mon ressenti c'est qu'il
faut d'abord à l'explorer la partie out
à l'intérieur de soi
oser croire en ses désirs et se faire
confiance
et oui car si notre véritable potentiel
se cacher dans une partie de nous que
nous aurions exclu consciemment ou
inconsciemment notre monde a besoin de
hinault qui sort de leur quête de
références de leur zone de confort et
qui dépassent leurs peurs pour tendre
concrètement la main aux autres
ok je suis d'accord avec vous la société
ne nous aide pas nous vivons dans un
monde hyper connecté mais nous sommes
coupés nos émotions
on devient peu à peu d anesthésier des
sortes de zombies numérique
on croit être in alors qu'on est dans
notre petit monde et pas dans le monde
et on oublie l'autre on suit aveuglément
des chemins de vie des chinois de vie
préconçues pré formaté
pendant cinq années de mon entrée en
classe prépa à ma sortie d'école de
commerce
je suis resté au seuil de moi même
j'étais peut-être in sur le papier mais
out deux mois l'apprentissage en école
mel c goût un peu amer de formatage des
comportements et d'un enseignement qui
était trop des incarnés par rapport à
l'urgence de réinventer du sens dans
l'économie une fois mon diplôme en poche
bien j'ai commencé dans une
multinationale mais je n'étais pas là où
je devais être
alors j'ai écouter mes désirs profonds
et j'ai fait le grand saut
j'ai d'abord été animatrice de réseau de
solidarité puis accompagnatrice auprès
de personnes âgées isolées en grande
précarité
puis dans une asso qui travaillait
auprès de jeunes diplômés des quartiers
et enfin je suis arrivé chez entourage
sur le projet linz
aujourd'hui je ne saurais pas vous dire
si je suis in si je suis out et à vrai
dire ça n'a pas d'importance je me suis
trouvée je suis mon hymne à moi et ça a
changé ma vie
alors ce soir je vous interroge qu'est
ce qui vous anime
vous aimez vous touche qu'est ce qui
vous donne de l'audace de l'énergie à
déplacer les montagnes mais surtout
qu'est ce qui manquera le plus au monde
si vous ne la portait pas je cite le
poète oriane monteyne dreamer
l'invitation je ne veux pas savoir ce
que vous faites dans la vie je veux
seulement connaître vos désirs savoir si
vous avez assez d'audace pour imaginer
la réalisation de vos rêves les plus
chers
je ne peux pas savoir quel âge vous avez
je veux savoir si vous oserez vous
rendent ridicules au nom de l'amour d'un
rêve ou de l' aventure de la vie
mon rêve à moi c'est qu'à votre tour
vous ayez le désir de révéler les
talents de tous les christine et les
jean-paul autour de vous est ce que
comme moi vous croyez que ça peut
transformer nos sociétés nos quartiers
nos villes que ça peut transformer le
monde
alors si vous aussi vous êtes convaincu
partagés sur vos réseaux sociaux
le cv d'un candidat lindhout pour elle
ou pour lui votre action peut tout
changer
merci beaucoup
[Musique]